nueva jornada en el combate de los
incendios que asolan desde hace más de
una semana al centro sur de chile y que
tienen a tres regiones bajo estado de
catástrofe el ñuble bío bío y Lara ocaña
fueron 321 los focos que combatieron los
diversos brigadistas bomberos fuerzas
armadas desplegadas en terrenos también
muchos voluntarios 94 de ellos
especialmente activos varios focos en la
comuna en la que nos encontramos walkie
se pudo ver fuego llamaradas desde
varios puntos de su Horizonte varios
foques que sucedían a la vez la ministra
del interior Carolina toja anunció que
se va a traer a un grupo de expertos
italianos para investigar el origen de
estos juegos ya hay 30 personas
detenidas por presunta intencionalidad
en el origen de estos fuegos y se va a
seguir una técnica forense para
determinar Cómo se produjeron varias
personas de las que con las que
hablábamos aquí varios vecinos de walkie
también denunciaban posible
intencionalidad en el origen de estos
incendios que vienen casti con fuerza y
han consumido más de 340.000 hectáreas
según afirman las autoridades dejado más
de dos decenas de personas fallecidas
2000 personas heridas y más de 1.250
casas totalmente destruidas Pero además
de eso también incendios que en un
sector especialmente rural y agrícola
dejan a muchas personas sin una forma de
continuar ganándose la vida el
presidente Gabriel borics visitó la
comuna de quillón en el núcleo y también
anunció que ha estado en conversaciones
con varios de sus padres
latinoamericanos para establecer un
posible equipamiento que incluyera
helicópteros y también aviones de Última
Generación para combatir los incendios
en toda la región